la guerre se poursuit en ukraine et les
réfugiés continuent d'affluer en france
il s'agit surtout de femmes et d'enfants
plus de 9600 jeunes ukrainiens sont
actuellement scolarisés principalement
dans les académies de nice et de
versailles a annoncé le ministère de
l'éducation nationale début mars nous
étions allés à la rencontre d'une
famille ukrainienne hébergé par daria à
voisins le bretonneux depuis trois
semaines deux soeurs ont réussi à
trouver une école le symbole que la vie
continue malgré tout on a attendu à peu
près une semaine et c'était vraiment pas
loin du tout par rapport à ce qu'on
pensait et après on était très très
contente de pouvoir reprendre des études
parce que rester à la maison on ressasse
et des mauvais souvenirs ça nous
déprimer je suis très célèbre collège
tout le monde cherche à venir me parler
ou à me demander quelque chose c'est
très touchant
la plus jeune a trouvé une place dans le
collège hélène boucher à voisins le
bretonneux olga elle suit actuellement
des cours à l'école des beaux-arts de
versailles je suis très contente d'être
à l'école des beaux-arts c'est une
chance j'ai trouvé une copine là bas
elle est japonaise elle m'aide beaucoup
elle me soutient et je trouve que les
gens me comprennent bien ils cherchent
tous à m'aider un monsieur très gentil
m'a acheté tous les nécessaires dont
j'avais besoin pour la peinture il nous
a invités dans le magasin et il a dit
choisissez tout ce que vous voulez je
vous l'achète ça me permet de dessiner
de plonger dans la peinture et je
voulais remercier ce monsieur
particulièrement olga viens d'une
famille de peintres son arrière grand
père ivan krasniqi a exposé des oeuvres
au musée national de kiev et dans divers
musées ukrainien très très bon
dessinateur des gens et on va aussi
travailler avec
le professeur de sculpture pour hockey
d'avoir un éventail de
deux possibilités pour exprimer j'ai
déjà vu que son un niveau dessin est
excellent il la prochaine fois elle va
certainement se mettre à la peinture
j'avais besoin de m'occuper pour me
détendre et me changer les idées et la
peinture c'est pour moi quelque chose
que j'adore et qui me fait du bien outre
la scolarisation marina et olga ont
également trouvé une activité
extrascolaire
je suis très contente de m'être inscrits
au badminton vraiment j'adore ça je
trouve que les gens sont très
accueillants très chaleureux c'est ce
que j'adore ici la danse c'est vraiment
ma vie j'adore danser et pour moi la
danse ça me permet d'oublier la raison
pour laquelle on s'est retrouvés ici
même si la guerre reste toujours
présente en arrière-plan les deux jeunes
filles se sentent intégrés dans leur
nouvelle activité et grâce à la mairie
de voisins-le-bretonneux la famille
d'olga et de maria a également trouvé
une maison au sein de la commune